the nevada family is pleading for the
safe return of a 15-year-old girl
tonight nomie armand deres was last seen
yesterday morning at her home on the
paiute reservation just outside of las
vegas and now those who love the teen
just want to bring her home safely sasha
loftus spoke with nomi's family tonight
and she's in our newsroom with more
denise and bryant nomie's family says
they just want her back they're calling
on the community but they're also
speaking to the teen herself saying they
won't give up until she's found
it's been a
living nightmare nearly two days since
she was last seen
the family of nomi armandaris is
pleading for her to come home when we
wake up we think of her when we go to
sleep she's the last thing we think
about nomi's sister evangelia tapia says
the 15 year old left her home here on
the paiute reservation tuesday around 5
a.m to go to school and she's been
missing ever since someone's influencing
her to do this someone's telling her
what to do tapia and nomi's uncle nino
alvarez call this out of character and
they're terrified she's with someone
else ultimately in danger she didn't
give us any kind of sign that this was
going to happen that's why they're
calling on las vegas and all of southern
nevada to come forward with any
information that could help
but more than anything they hope to
speak to nomi herself you just tell us
that you're scared
and that you
that you want us to come get you and
we'll come get you to remind her how
much they love her
and how they don't want to face any kind
of future
without her tell me just please come
home
nomi is five foot two with brown eyes
and black and red hair if you have seen
her if you have any information you are
asked to call the paiute police
department at 702-471-0844
or the las vegas fbi we have more
information on our website
8newsnow.com reporting in the newsroom
tonight sasha loftis live local now